اكد المتحدث باسم الخارجيه الصينيه
جولجيان خلال مؤتمر صحفي ان سياسه بلاده
في مكافحه فيروس كوبي 19
ستكون ناجحه من خلال تعاوني ودعم جميع
المواطنين
اضافها
تتبع سياسه التصفير الديناميكي في حربها
ضد الفيروس بناء على تطورات الوضع
الوبائيه في البلاد
التصفير الديناميكي وسياسات اخرى بناء على
الوضع الوبائي تم اجراء تعديلات ونحن الان
ننفذ الاصداره التاسعه من خطه الوقايه
والسيطره على الوداع نعتقد انه مع قياده
الحزب الشيوعي وتعاون ودعم جميع الناس فان
سياسه مكافحه الفايروس ستنجح بالتاكيد
من بيجين معنا مراسله الجزيره شيماء
الجوئي شيماء كيف بدات العاصمه
بيجين في ضوئي
المظاهرات الرافضه
لسياسه صفر كفيل وهل يتوقع ان تستجيب
السلطات كما حصلت اقليم شنقيان
من خلفي في الحقيقه في مدينه مثل البيجين
تضم على الاقل 21 مليون نسمه الحركه قليله
جدا بالنسبه
للحركه المعتده في شوارع العاصمه
بيجين هنالك مناطق مصنفه على انها متوسطه
وعاليه الخطوره مثل منطقه
التي نتواجد فيها حاليا الحركه قليله
بخصوصا بعد الرسائل النصيه التي ترسلها
السلطات للمواطنين باجراء فحص كوب بتسعه
عشر بشكل يومي وتجنب الخروج الى الشوارع
الا للضروره القصوى المقاهي والمطاعم
واماكن الترفيه على العامه جميعها مغلقه
هنالك استجابه لهذه الاحتجاجات التي بدات
شعلتها منذ الاسبوع الماضي تحديدا في
مدينه
وسط الصين التي كانت من قبل مجموعه من
العمال في مصنع لصناعه الهواتف الذكيه
بالصين والذين احتاجوا على سوء احوالهم
الصح المعيشيه داخل خطوط الانتاج في
المصنع هم مطربون بتطبيق سياسه الحلقه
المغلقه التي تنص على بقائهم عند خطوط
الانتاج حيث يقومون بالعمل نهارا ويبيتون
ليلا هناك ولا يعرفون متى تنتهي هذه
السياسه ومتى يعودون الى اهاليهم وذويهم
بعد هذه الاحتجاجات في جنتو شاهدنا
احتجاجات في مدينه ارموتشي حضرت مقاطعه
شنجان غربيه البلاد بعد حريقا اود بحياه
10 اشخاص في مبنى سكني ومطالبات الصينيين
على مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي بمعرفه اسباب
هذا الحادث واجراء التحقيقا مستقلا لمعرفه
ما اذا كانت فرق الانقاذ قد وصلت متاخره
الى موقع الحريق بسبب الاغلاقات التي
تعيشها على المدينه منذ نحو ثلاثه اشهر او
ما يقرب من 100 يوم شنجان تعيش هذا
الاغلاق وايضا منطقه اقليم ايضا تعيش
اغلاقا منذ نحو ثلاثه اشهر هنالك استجابه
رايناها اليوم بالفعل حسن من قبل السلطات
المحليه لمدينه ارموتشي التي قالت بانها
ستقوم بتخفيف من هذه الاجراءات همم ابتداء
من اليوم الاثنين وعوده المواصلات العامه
للعمل تدريجيا ابتداءا من اليوم كذلك
اليوم السلطات المحليه في العاصمه بيجين
اكدت بانها تتعامل مع الوضع عن كتب وبانها
ستحاول تخفيف الاجراءات بحيث لا يكون
هنالك ضرر او اضرار وتاثير على حياه
السكان والمواطنين في حياتهم اليوميه
وخلال لا اذهبهم الى اشغلهم ايضا المتحدث
باسم الخارجيه الصينيه اكد بان الصين تتبع
السياسه محدده جدا من خلال سياسه صفر كوفد
او زيرو كوفيدوتي تقوم بتطبيقها في كل
المناطق وليس فقط في العاصمه الصينيه
شكرا لك يا شيماء
مراسله الجزيره